[Musique]
un poumon en évidence ça va ça va juste
un peu tendu en tout cas je te trouve
très élégant tu me connais j'ai pas
envie de me planter ça fait au moins six
mois que tu prépares cette réunion tu es
crif
attention j'ai une question papa une
guide papa aime qu il est exact papa va
décrocher le jackpot est gay monsieur
hire votre famille apprécié son séjour
énormément ils n'en reviennent pas de
vous nous ayez donné tous les tâches à
l'issue de votre dite de sécurité que
pensez vous de notre tour sauf votre
respect ce n'est qu'un vigile mis sur un
piédestal
je vous en prie le pearl et la
construction la plus haute et la plus
sophistiqués au monde
vous avez bâti une ville verticale mais
vous y avez introduit tous les problèmes
de sûreté et de sécurité possibles et
imaginables
on pensait que l'état j'étais vide moi
aussi non seulement ils sont concentrés
dans ses murs mais il se trouve aussi
coincé sur une hauteur de 240 étage
personne ne peut prévoir ce qui
arriverait en cas d'incident mais je ne
suis qu'un vigile sur un piédestal alors
qu'est ce que j'en sais après tout
qu'est-ce qu'il ya le 96e est en feu
tout va bien se passer ces premiers
[Musique]
dis moi à quel point tu tiens ta famille
si on veut sortir d'ici il va falloir me
dire la vérité
ils n'ont pas choisi cette tour par
hasard
en ce moment la seule chose qui compte
c'est ma famille
[Musique]